why during the 1950s
did something happen that resulted in a
70-year
stagnation in a field called quantum
gravity quantum gravity is like a
startup that cannot ship a product after
70 years
and it's still taken over in theoretical
physics as sort of The Prestige Theory
field
and quantum gravity is is there an
application for this that they were
attempting to achieve it's not a
precursor to technology so far as we
know but what happened was quantum
gravity was a replacement for something
that used to be known as the unified
field so Einstein wasn't chasing quantum
gravity he was chasing unified field
theory that fell out of favor unified
field Theory becomes sort of like a joke
old-timey expression for the future of
physics and we substituted quantum
gravity for the merger of quantum theory
one field Theory quantum mechanics and
gravitational physics under general
relativity how is it that the field
became convinced
that something which clearly doesn't
seem to work and has had all of the
resources all of the best Minds at its
disposal it sucks up everything and it
it just doesn't work to be specific like
how many people are working on this
problem and how many people have been
working on this problem for 70 years
without progress I would say that the
period between 1953 and 73 there are
parallel things quantum gravity is not
the mainstream at all okay so real
physics is happening between 53 and 73
by anybody's understanding of it okay
one single individual who is the most
dominant mind on planet Earth at the
moment
effectively Voldemort the person whose
name we are a little bit afraid to
invoke and and cause Wrath
said in 1984. now string theory is the
way this anomaly cancellation was
unexpected and it clearly points to the
fact that we are ladies and gentlemen we
are about to quantize who's that person
Edward Whitton
and in physics circles you're not
allowed to bring this guy up oh we talk
about him everybody talks about him but
to challenge him
think about agent Smith
think about playing one-on-one with
Michael Jordan in his prime
he's not good Joe I don't think I'm dumb
enough not to be intellectually afraid
of anyone else on planet Earth at this
point
I am terrified of this person really
and has never made a contact with the
physical world
so it's like one of the greatest
conundrums so so let me get back to how
crazy you mean by never made contact no
Nobel Prize never predicted something
that turned out to be true never pointed
us to do an experiment that was
invalidated so a hundred percent of his
efforts have been not making contact
with physical reality oh this is
I'm sorry like you have people like
Michio Kaku who are in the string
theoretic School Sean Carroll is very
sympathetic to it you need to understand
this story 1957 conference at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
one of the most eminent mathematician
physicists guy was first Wrangler at
Cambridge was a guy named Herman Bondi
an Austrian I think mathematician in his
paper is about negative mass in general
relativity
if you have two masses in general they
always attract each other
gravitationally
but what if somehow you had a different
kind of mass that was negative just like
you could have negative and positive
charges
oddly the negative mass is still
attracted just the same way to the
positive masses if it there was no
difference but the positive mass is
always repelled so you get this weird
solution where the negative Mass chases
the positive mass and they go off to
like you know unbounded acceleration
so Bondi was thinking about why is it
that we've got these artificial
conditions in general relativity which
we impose by hand they're not the same
beautiful marble that Einstein used for
his field equations but we throw some
extra crappy stuff in called positivity
conditions to stop general relativity
from giving us Madness
so Bondi started asking the question
maybe we shouldn't maybe what you think
of is madness has meaning
and this is why
this this conference which is a
Confluence of the two families the
wittens and the dewitts with Feynman and
Wheeler and all of these unbelievable
characters in attendance
is this pivotal strange experience is
that people are smoking the ganja
on extending general relativity to
places that it's never been extended and
the highbrow version of this doesn't
work and the lowbrow version of this
doesn't work so far as we know the low
brow version is called pseudoscientific
anti-gravity gravity shielding
electrogravidics
gravity Dynamics
the highbrow version of this is called
quantum gravity
and all the most respectable people are
in it and it doesn't work and you can't
say why are we doing this if it doesn't
work
why can't I say edwinton's great but he
made a terrible blunder David Gross
should David Gross and Ed Whitton should
be in front of the community explaining
why did you take all the smartest people
all the resources all the attention
Michio Kaku get Michio kako in here with
me
Michio Kaku is out of control
Sean Carroll is covering up for this as
well
in what way
they are too kind Brian Green like I had
this interchange with Brian Greene where
I said you know
were
not being honest
about the failure of string theory and
Brian's like oh well maybe we were a
little bit exuberant and I could blurt
out Institute for arts and ideas I
blurred out
that's like saying milai
milai was irrational exuberance no you
put a lot of people's careers in the in
the shredder in order to have this
quantum gravity experiment which is like
you know the people bowing and praying
to this thing that doesn't work
the dog doesn't hunt and anybody who
questions it is a crackpot I'm done with
this Joe like you want to come at me and
say Eric doesn't know what he's talking
about I'm debating physicists I'll
debate anybody with the possible
conception of Ed Whitton who still
scares me but I'll probably debate him
too
in open Forum we have got to purge
the physics community of its quackery
and the quackery is coming from the high
Prestige version of this the high
Prestige version of anti-gravity is
called quantum gravity and it just
doesn't work
they've crawled into the map the prison
built by Einstein and they know that
it's not right
because there are these two
singularities there's this Singularity
at the beginning of time which we call
the big bang
assuming the time we're one dimensional
and it's part of something called the
Friedman Robertson Walker space-time
model
and there's another one at the bottom of
the black hole called The schwarzgled
Singularity and the fact that space and
time Kink at these two points is an
indication that we have something wrong
to a mathematician or a physicist it
says your equations work pretty well
right up into the point where there's
some error that you have that you don't
understand and you have like a division
by zero error
and if you could figure out your error
you don't know what sin you committed
but the way that you know you committed
a sin is that you have a singularity so
they know that there's some successor
Theory and they'll give lectures about
space-time is doomed and I'm going to
talk about non-commutative geometry but
these are all ways of avoiding the fact
that you haven't done your homework for
50 years okay
so like there's some class that you're
supposed to show up to and you haven't
been in a long time you don't want to
show up and suddenly say what what's
going on
um
that's what's happening they are living
inside of Einstein's model So when you
say something they'll say well that's
impossible
because you can't go faster than the
speed of light it's like that's a
space-time concept that's an einsteining
concept you're not thinking post
einsteining you're not thinking about
recovering Einstein or Einstein is what
we would call an effective Theory you're
thinking that you really live in
space-time so you know what you can do
and then you fold your arms and say well
that's impossible
[Music]
foreign